back and into our q a the energy price
cap has officially been lifted that
means millions of households are now
facing a huge hike in their monthly
bills
let's take you through the figures the
price cap is increasing by 54 or
693 pounds a year that means annual
energy costs for many are jumping from
1277 pounds to
1971 pounds
it's estimated that'll impact around 22
million households now the price
increase is being driven largely by the
cost of wholesale energy which we've
seen has risen sharply
and of course it's not just energy bills
national insurance contributions are
also going up by 1.25 percentage points
this month and the rate of inflation
well that is expected to reach a 40-year
high of 8.7
well over the next half hour we are
going to be looking at some of the
questions you have been sending in about
the cost of living crisis uh joining me
now is a panel of experts we have
richard newdeg
head of regulation and compliance at
uswitch uh charlotte jessup director of
looking after your pennies
tara evans set head of consumer at the
sun
and we're also joined by karen isaac who
works two jobs herself and is on
universal credit
well thank you very much sir to all of
our guests uh for being with us uh today
we really appreciate your input uh over
the next half hour with uh questions
from uh our audience i want to start
before we get into the to the advice i
want to start karen with you and with
your situation uh because as we said
you're working uh two jobs you're
claiming universal credit what does the
cost of living crisis feel like and look
like from where you're standing
terrible and just wondering where it's
all going to end i'm 64. i've as you
just said i've got two jobs
um well i can't get above universal
credit um
it's just terrible i live rurally and so
my house is heated by oil and as you all
know the price of that has gone up so
intensely um i'm just walking around
with a hot water bottle a lot of the
time because the house is so cold yeah i
wonder i mean we are going to come to to
questions from our audience as well but
certainly as you are relying on oil i
wonder richard
if there's any advice you have for karen
in this sort of short term on what she
might be able to do for those bills
it's really difficult for those on on
heating old to be honest there's there's
no real regulation there's no clothes
there's no price cap and heating oil
most people you've got heating are
already used to the tips of when best to
buy it when best to top up and things
but but cam's right like the bills have
gone up massively there and there
actually is is very little that can be
done more needs to be done really to
protect those that are reliant on eating
all
yeah i'm and i imagine uh charlotte
certainly uh you've been hearing lots of
people in karen's situation let's let
not everybody is reliant on oil in the
way that karen is have you got any
advice uh for her there
i mean it is a tough one and it's a lot
of it is outside of the individual's
control i think it would be
wrong with me to sit here and sort of
suggest little things that you can do
around her house but actually there's a
much bigger picture going on here i
think that probably a lot of the things
that she's doing already are
over and above what we should expect of
people to be doing in this situation but
i think you know keep keeping an eye on
the money for people who are in a
similar situation keep an eye on the
money make sure you know what the
figures are and you know if there are
little things that you can do or do
around your house then then do those
because it will make the difference in
the long run but i think what she's
doing already sounds like
plenty
and tara do you have a lot of people uh
or do you hear from a lot of people in
karen's sort of position
yeah our you know our post bags are
completely full of um people in current
situation and one thing i would say is
there are um
grants and hardship funds that you can
apply for i would really urge her to
contact someone like turn to us um and
search for a grant i would also try your
local council because they will have um
pots of money as part of the household
support fund
um which you can apply for all of this
is discretionary so there's no guarantee
you'll get it but it's always worth
trying
um those roots as well okay well
brilliant thanks very much uh for that
for kicking us off we are going to get
into the questions that you have been
sending in thank you for doing uh so
with a question from michael uh first of
all and richard at you switch i'm going
to direct this first question to you so
michael asks is it worth shopping around
for a better electricity deal or will
all supplies be at the maximum price now
uh richard what do you make of that
yes so those standard variable plans
that most of us are on almost all
suppliers are at or very very close to
that price cap so it's going to be very
difficult to get less than that um i
mean we've spent a usage 20 years
telling people to shop around to save on
energy but at the moment really there
aren't good fixed deals out there
because of the conditions in the
wholesale market and so for the vast
majority of this unfortunately sticking
with what you have is probably going to
be the best or very close to the best
that you can do it is worth setting up
alerts and things in case there are
deals that come back on the market we
have seen a couple of suppliers who've
offered decent uh fixed rate deals to
their existing customers but these are
they appear very very briefly and then
get snapped up but even then they're not
a discount significant discount to the
price cap they're going to be freezing
the kind of price cut level or even
slightly above and more about protecting
yourself against potential even future
rises to the price cap further down the
line yeah we've certainly heard the same
from people like martin lewis saying
just stick do nothing it's the only
thing you can do which sounds sort of
depressing but it is the reality that
we're living it at the moment um let's
go straight to another uh question this
one from rochelle and i'm going to uh
throw this one charlotte towards you so
looking after your pennies uh rochelle
asks what can i do if i can't afford the
direct debit amount that my supplier is
now wanting uh from me uh so charlotte
what would you say to that what what can
you do if you simply cannot afford it
yeah this is a really tough one and i i
don't think this person is going to be
alone in this situation we there's been
lots of people receiving letters and be
like well how am i supposed to pay for
this i think the thing that i'm urging
people to do is to speak to their
suppliers so make a contact and have
this conversation your supplier will
have to have this conversation with you
and create a plan about how you can
afford it essentially i mean i'm
assuming that they've looked at you know
other areas of their finances and and
made sure that
you know any any wiggle room that they
do have they've already addressed but i
think speak speak to the suppliers it's
the first thing and if you can't
do anything there reach out to people
like citizens advice they will be able
to take a more sort of holistic view at
your financial situation and see if
there's any other support or options
that are available to you
karen i'd like to bring you in on that
because you this is lived experience for
you as well i think you said your role
uh company was asking for 800 pounds or
so up front something you couldn't
afford so you've been sitting in the
cold as a result of that i mean if you
were speaking to rochelle who who can't
afford that direct debit is there
anything you've done that might be able
to help her
no at the top of my head really as like
every one of the experts are saying
there isn't a lot you can do at the
moment there really isn't um
i've
been told that you can really do
something like try to join a
co-operative round where you live try to
find other people that are buying you
know the same sort of fuel as you to
heat their home and maybe um join
together and buy together because it
could be cheaper but i don't know a lot
about that but that is one thing i've
been told and have found out about
okay that's really interesting uh right
some live yeah lived experience some
advice uh from uh from karen there as
well uh adrian has a question and this
one i'm gonna send tara your way uh
adrian asks at what stage will we see
prices
come back down tara if you've got any
thoughts on that
it's really hard to say when prices are
going to come back down and but we do
know that the price cap will be
reevaluated
in october this year
really worryingly estimates out today
have suggested that it's going to go up
by 600 pounds which isn't the news that
anybody wants um and that will mean that
energy bills would have doubled in the
last year um it really is reliant on
these wholesale prices um which are
unfortunately linked to the crisis in
ukraine um and also many other factors
so it's really keeping an eye on things
and you know preparing as best you can
for any further rises yeah and it's
really hard not to end up feeling like
you're you're doom-mongering and
potentially uh frightening people even
more but you're absolutely right
cornwall insight i think uh suggested
that in in october when that price cap
is reviewed uh those prices could go up
another 29
which seems completely
beyond the realm of comprehension um i
wonder uh for richard again if you're
looking at
you know people who are trying to
compare between prices how they might do
it
do you have any sense of when the fog
might clear and when you might be able
to actually find some good deals again
when those prices might start to come
down
i think unfortunately as tara is saying
that we're not done with the price
increases just yet because of the
situation with russia and ukraine but
also other factors as well that are
driving up those wholesale prices i
think we will see them go up
significantly again in october hopefully
after that when some of that fog does
clearly would start to see some prices
come down again but i think that the
really difficult situation is here i
don't think we're going back to the
levels of pricing you can see you could
get a you know average consumption a
cheap deal around 800 pounds i don't
think we're going back to that we'd love
to go back to that i don't think we are
so while they should come off the boil
to the extremes that we will be probably
in october we're not going back to
really cheap energy which raises really
big questions for affordability in the
long term and making sure that those in
the most vulnerable circumstances get
the real level of support they need the
existing support schemes in the energy
industry have barely moved they've moved
a little bit or going up a little bit
but it's nowhere near the quantum of
actual costs that people are facing so
more needs to be thought about there for
sure charlotte would you agree with that
have you got a sense that you know we
are really at the beginning of this
crisis and actually when we look at the
next let's say year or two horizon
certainly uh it's not going to get any
better and people aren't going to be
finding uh more money so you know
looking after your pennies is one thing
but actually if you don't have those
pennies how on earth can you look after
them
yeah no it's absolutely true and and
we've seen lots of experts come out and
say the same thing it definitely feels
like we're at the start of something and
that we
what really needs to happen is some
government intervention something
something beyond just you know
looking after being frugal or you know
taking care with this bill or spending a
little less here and you know meal
planning and all these things that i've
been preaching to people for you know
the last few years
this this is not going to cut it in the
longer term scheme it needs something
outside outside of our household money
management systems that we've been using
so far yeah certainly and it feels like
with inflationary forces with global uh
forces that this is certainly much
bigger than household uh budgets and
household bills let's move on to another
uh question which is going to go richard
to you this question from gary
who asks i'm going to be moving into my
first home in the next couple of weeks
well congratulations to you gary uh
should i look to get a fixed rate deal
with my energy supply once i've moved in
with the anticipation of the cap getting
raised again in the winter
or should i stick with a variable rate i
mean that is a question i guess anyone
uh who's looking to change uh their
current plan or who's starting a new one
might be facing uh richard what would
you suggest
but again congratulations to gary on
getting your first home that's great
news
uh the truth is you're gonna struggle to
find a fixed deal that is um better than
the price cap and you're going to
struggle probably to find one that's
better than even the price cap might be
in october that doesn't mean that it's
not worth seeing what the current
provider will offer and like when you
move the house you tend to inherit the
provider that is already there and they
put you on the deemed tower that's the
price cap tariffs you won't really have
a choice supplier see if they'll offer
you anything that's anywhere reasonable
but the chances are you're probably just
going to need to stick with that price
count tariff and then see what happens
in october unfortunately charlotte would
you agree with that
absolutely i think a lot of the fixed
ratios at the moment about 40 above the
um the price cap and actually even if
you factor in the
suggested increases that are potentially
gonna be happening in october um it will
still be that the price cap should still
be less than some of those fixed deals
so unfortunately it say it seems like
it's just a case of holding tight and
waiting and seeing
tara i'm gonna i'm gonna throw it to you
as well i mean i assume you're gonna
agree i keep wondering maybe someone
will pull a rabbit out of a hat but i
feel like that's not going to happen
would you agree with with both richard
and charlotte on that tara
sadly i do agree um i would say as
richard said earlier there are some like
fixed deals coming through that are
available for like a matter of hours so
i would sign up to newsletters and price
alerts to make sure that you can find
out about those because you might get
lucky it's also worth asking your
supplier about those deals as well
because they may be offering those deals
to current
um current customers um and yeah
unfortunately it is about you know if
you really are in trouble and you are in
hardship and speak to your supplier
because lots of them do have hardship
funds um they have pots of cash that
they are distributing to customers who
are in fuel poverty so if you are in
trouble then really do speak to a
supplier and know it's easy to stick
your head in the ground but they will be
the ones who'll be able to help you
right now
that's that's an interesting point
actually because this idea of reaching
out human to human to your energy
provider seems to be something that's
fallen by the wayside we think of them
as big companies we often hear of people
spending days on the phone not being
able to get through karen is that
something you've thought about doing
calling your energy provider and if you
have what's their response been
um well i did contact the oil company
that i'm with and i've been with them
for over 25 years um and they were just
um you know understanding and everything
but they still wanted their money the
end of the financial year before they
you know actually give me a delivery at
800 pounds or so you know
even though i've always kept a dialogue
going with them i always let them know
if there's problems which i think
everyone should do
um it hasn't really helped in my
situation but um i'd like to sort of
mention really i thought it'd be great
if all the companies came together and
they could actually
have a website or something where it's
all together in one place and if that's
anything anyone's thought of so the
consumer could actually um access that
without having to go all over the place
you know it would all be in one place
especially
are you talking karen about advice or
are you talking about comparing
different prices between different
companies
everything but advice mainly i think so
i guess
for competition reasons it would be hard
for them to all sign up for that
themselves but i do imagine and taro i
mean what are your views on this uh i do
imagine that yeah if you go to a sort of
money-saving expert
other websites are available of course
but if you do go to some of the the
comparison websites that might be
a place to start tara what do you think
that would be the sun the money section
on the sun but also
also there are um lots of really good
advice on citizens advice and they have
pulled together a really good list of
all the hardship funds um so if that's
something you're looking for that's a
great place to start there is loads of
advice out there um and you know you're
not alone do speak to your supplier yeah
absolutely and whilst we're mentioning
of course you've got looking after your
pennies represented by charlotte here
and you switch represented uh by richard
there is advice out there and it is hard
because it does mean spending a lot of
time on the internet trying to find that
advice
let's let's bring in our next uh viewer
and our next question this one from jane
and i'm gonna send this one tara your
way again
i've heard there was a deadline
yesterday to send in meter readings i
didn't know about this have i missed out
uh tara has jane missed out
firstly don't panic um there was a
deadline yesterday it was you know coin
national me today meter reading day but
you haven't missed out many of the
suppliers are allowing you up to seven
days to um submit these meter readings
um lots of the websites have been busy
many of them been crashing even today
some of them have been struggling with
the sheer volume it's also important to
note that if you have a fixed deal at
the moment or you're you have a smart
meter then you don't need to do this but
it might be wise to take a picture um if
the website or your provider you can't
get online and there's no way to submit
it then i would take a photograph
because then you will have evidence and
that will help if they you know if there
is any problem or discrepancy between
what energy you're being charged for
richard have you found that on the whole
companies have been pretty good about
responding to those even if they're late
meter readings
i i think yeah suppliers are going to
accept meter readings that come at this
point um for the following days
obviously they've not been good at
accepting them because their websites
crashed but i think there is a there is
a more important point here with me to
readings like it's not going to change
the price for charge the reason people
people have been saying to take a meter
reading is to make sure that you're not
accidentally charged for usage you've
already had at this new higher rate
because suppliers estimate bills when
you don't have a smart meter but it is
actually really good practice to give
regular meter readings every every every
regular period we would say once a month
if you're not on a smart meter and the
reason is for that is so your ng account
doesn't get out of step with your direct
debit if you're paying by direct debit
the problem is is when suppliers have to
estimate they can get this wrong and
particularly if you are doing things at
home to save energy usage as well the
trap is that they then come after you
later when you do get a meter reading or
they send someone around to do a meter
reading and then say actually your
direct debits got to go up a lot more a
lot of things that we've been hearing
are that we obviously know prices are
going up 54
people's direct debit reviews have been
much worse than that because
they've been caught up with usage and
particularly as we look forward towards
winter where most of the the usage we
have across the year is and that's the
period where we think the price tap is
going to go up again it's so important
to be up to date with that make your
account updated give regular media
readings so you know what you're faced
with and can budget as best you can and
what is a very very difficult situation
yeah that's definitely a very practical
piece of advice that people can do right
away which is essentially set a reminder
in your in your phone uh every month
make sure you take a photo of your meter
reading i wonder if the websites are
down at the moment richard uh and you
can't submit that meter reading but you
really want to make sure you're you're
not paying the much higher price uh for
previous usage
is there any way of taking a photo
somehow dating that photo and and
they'll use that as proof
yeah you can do that if you want to be
sure just you know make a mistake or
make sure you did it that particular
time there are other forms you can give
me to readings as well it varies by
supply but some have an app there's a
website you can call them up so i have
an automated line so you're not waiting
in a queue and there are plenty of
different ways uh to do it but it really
isn't going to make a huge amount of
difference whether you do it now or a
week from now the important thing is to
do it at some point and then to do it
regularly and as you said i think
suppliers will be pretty good about
accepting the date you know putting it
for the date of the 31st of march or
today if you've done it today so do take
the meter reading make a note of it and
trying to give it to your supplier as
soon as possible but just get into that
bit regularly and make sure your energy
account doesn't get out of step i think
is an important thing to take away all
right good advice there for uh jane uh
let's crack on with our next uh question
this one from jamie and i'm going to
send it charlotte uh towards uh you
jamie asks with these fuel increases and
poverty rife in 21st century britain are
households going to have to cancel
christmas this year goodness i mean i
can't believe in april beginning of
april we're talking about christmas
already but it's got to be done um
charlotte are we going to have to cancel
christmas again not for covid
i hope not um i think i think if any
year we need something to look forward
to but i genuinely under understand the
concern here with you know increasing
costs
the first things to go in our budget are
the things that are fun and enjoyable we
like strip everything back and we focus
on the essentials i would say that it
it's still uncertain i think a lot of
families are going to find christmas
tougher this year
i will give the same kind of uh advice
and guidance that i give in every year
and this is that
christmas is is more affordable if you
think about it early so you know start
planning if you could afford a little
bit now then that's great start putting
some of that money aside put some plans
in place or maybe this is the year that
you you sit down with your extended
family and you have a conversation about
what christmas means to you and what is
affordable within your household so yes
christmas can still happen um
it might just look a little different
for some of us this year yeah all right
well thank you uh let's have another
question this time from dave richard
this one's for you uh dave asks it's
been suggested to me that if you don't
sorry that if you do have solar on your
house you won't have to pay v80 on the
electricity bill i've been looking for
some confirmation of this or is it an
april fool richard
so unfortunately having solar panels
won't prevent you will not stop you
paying your vat on your energy bills i
suspect where this has come from is in
the spring statement the government had
announced that for installation of solar
panels and other energy efficiency
measures that help us use less energy
that you have to obviously pay up front
they're going to make that exempt from
from v80 that's currently on that so
there is a benefit if you're looking to
get solar panels installed but that
comes with a big upfront cost if you
have solar panels it's great because you
will have a bit of saving if you can use
that energy yourself where you get the
feed in tariff back so you will save a
bit on bills in general but not the v80
that's still going to be charged for
your gas electricity that you're getting
for them all right now we are
nearly out of time so i'm very conscious
we have to race through our last couple
of points um tara this one's for you
uh and this one uh is anonymously uh
submitted but it says why is the price
of energy rising exponentially in
comparison with the considerably less
percentage rise in the eu so why is it
that we're suffering so badly in the uk
tara
well i mean price rises will depend on
the deals that suppliers have bought and
different markets will work in different
ways i think the key thing here is that
they are rising everywhere um in other
countries they are also seeing rises so
it really is about you know making sure
that you are on top of your bills and
are planning ahead so you're thinking
about you know can you afford this
rights now and you know if there are
future rises how are you going to budget
for those as well okay great thank you
tara karen i'd like to have the last
word uh with you i'd love to know number
one if you've felt that there's advice
that you can take away from what we've
heard uh today and also
whether you feel that any political
party has a plan that might help someone
like you
um well first question is yes i have
been listening intently and it's lovely
to hear some of the things that have
been said that should help um the second
thing is um
i think it definitely not the
conservatives they're just not um really
doing much so i mean i really don't know
because
all of them are all going to do
something and nothing ever happens for
the real person the person in the street
that's working hard you know yeah
absolutely and karen it's been great to
hear from you thank you for sharing your
experiences uh thank you to all of i
guess i'm sorry we're out of time uh
thanks all very much for giving us your
advice you are watching sky news on our
q a coming up the news hour with
jonathan samuels they'll be talking more
about the cost of living crisis and
speaking to